حسنًا ، قال الرئيس الروسي إن لديه الآن
أسلحة نووية في وضع الاستعداد في بيلاروسيا ،
وهذا هو المكان الذي شن فيه فلاديمير بوتين
غزوه لأوكرانيا منذ أكثر من عام عندما
تحدث يوم الجمعة تفاخر بوتين
بعدد الأسلحة النووية التي تمتلكها روسيا
مع بعض الكلمات المختارة لحلف الناتو.
هذه الأسلحة أكثر من
دول الناتو ، فهم يعرفون ذلك
ويواصلون إخبارنا ببدء مفاوضات بشأن
التخفيضات جيدًا ، فأنت تعلم جيدًا ما يمكنهم
دفعه
بينما يقول بوتين إن هناك
خطرًا جسيمًا يتمثل في انجرار الناتو إلى
الحرب من خلال تزويد
أوكرانيا و  يقول إنه
سيتم إرسال المزيد من الأسلحة النووية إلى بيلاروسيا
طوال فصل الصيف كتحذير
للغرب بشأن دعم أوكرانيا
لمزيد من ندا بشير تنضم إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة من
لندن ، وهو صوت عدائي للغاية لبوتين
مع تحذير للغرب ،
نعم ، كان فجأة مقاتلًا في بلده
لهجة ليلى على الرغم من أنه كان واضحًا في
رسالته هذا الخط الذي سمعناه كثيرًا
من الرئيس بوتين خلال
غزوه لأوكرانيا أنه بالنسبة للكرملين
من منظور موسكو ، يتعلق الأمر
بالاحتواء ، فهذا يتعلق
بأمن الدولة الروسية الآن كما
ذكرت أن هذا فقط
الدفعة الأولى من الرؤوس الحربية النووية التكتيكية التي سيتم
نشرها في بيلاروسيا بالطبع
داعم رئيسي للرئيس بوتين طوال
غزوه لأوكرانيا ، وليس من المتوقع أن يكتمل
النقل الكامل للأسلحة التكتيكية النووية التي سيتم
نشرها في بيلاروسيا
بنهاية  سيتم
وضع الصيف على أهبة الاستعداد هناك مع
احتدام الحرب لكن الرئيس بوتين يكرر مرة أخرى
أن الأمر بالنسبة لموسكو يتعلق
بالاحتواء ، فهذه خطوة
تم تطويرها لضمان
أمن الدولة لروسيا على حد قوله ،
استمع إلى
استخدام الأسلحة النووية.  مما لا شك فيه
أنه من الممكن نظريًا بالنسبة لروسيا بالنسبة
لروسيا ، فمن الممكن إذا كان هناك
تهديد
لاستقلال استقلالنا وسيادتنا الإقليمية
لوجود الدولة الروسية
الآن في هذا العصر ، وتقول الحكومة الأمريكية
إنها تراقب الوضع عن كثب
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالانتشار.  من
الأسلحة النووية التكتيكية في بيلاروسيا ، لكنه
لا يرى أي مؤشر على أن الكرملين لديه
أي خطط لاستخدام الأسلحة النووية ضد
أوكرانيا ، ولا يوجد سبب يدعو الولايات المتحدة إلى تعديل
موقفها النووي في هذه المرحلة ،
ولكن هذا بالطبع أثار ناقوس الخطر
داخل أوكرانيا وبين
حلف الناتو.  لقد سمعنا حلفاء من
سفراء أوكرانيا في المملكة المتحدة
يحذرون من أن بي ويست يجب أن يأخذ
هذه الخطوة على محمل الجد ، وكما
ذكرت هناك ، فقد وجه الرئيس بوتين
تحذيره الخاص للغرب مع التركيز على
حلف الناتو محذرًا من إمكانية
استقطابهم.  أبعد وأعمق في هذا
الصراع من خلال إمدادهم بالأسلحة
إلى أوكرانيا بالطبع مع ملاحظة أن روسيا
لديها مخزون أكبر من
الرؤوس الحربية النووية التكتيكية أكبر من مخزون حلف الناتو